[Musique]
nous sommes en 1679 pour échapper aux
tumultes de la cour versaillaise louis
xiv décide de faire construire ce
château à marly ainsi que douze
pavillons pour ses convives
sept ans plus tard il effectue son
premier séjour en compagnie d'une
société choisie pour y être invitée il
fallait prononcer sir marly à l'oreille
du roi une fois que louis xiv avait
dressé la liste des heureux élus à à
marly et bien cette liste a été écrite
et afficher montrer à versailles et puis
c'est l'occasion à la cour de commenter
l'état de la faveur de telle ou telle
personne auprès du roi après trois ans
de fermeture le musée du domaine royal
de marly propose aux visiteurs une
nouvelle identité et différents espaces
qui permettent d'entrer encore plus dans
l'intimité du roi soleil
cette nouvelle salle met en avant les
loisirs pratiqués lorsque l'on venait
séjourné dans cette résidence
[Musique]
plus d'interactivité également dans ce
nouveau parcours avec une représentation
de la route de la machine de marly à
l'échelle 1 5e ce gigantesque dispositif
de pompage des eaux de la senne servait
à alimenter notamment les jardins du
château et cette maquette elle et a
servi un vidéo projecteur qui va
profiter des lumières sur cette cascade
factice l'eau elle arrive au sommet de
la duc de louveciennes qui existe
toujours aujourd'hui et elle vient
remplir le réservoir de la machine de la
le réservoir distribuer l'eau dans les
fontaines une expérience de réalité
virtuelle permettent également de
revivre les clips de soleil 2715 aux
côtés de louis xiv
à la mort du roi le château continue à
être occupé par louis 15 et louis saez
la dernière salle du parcours évoque le
destin du domaine la révolution le
château de marly et est vendu il est
acquis par un particulier qui conserve
en main propre quelques années et puis
aux alentours de 1806 ition 1808 il est
des ruines et donc il cherche à se
séparer du château ils ne trouvent pas
acquéreur pour le vendre tel qu'il est
donc ils décident de le démolir en
espérant pouvoir vendre plus facilement
le terrain 9 en tout plus de 180 objets
exposés permettent d'en savoir un peu
plus sur l'univers de louis xiv
[Musique]